hey I'm Savannah I'm 25 years old I am
an ex Republican and now Democrat hi my
name is Kat I'm 27 years old and I am an
ex Democrat who now identifies as an
independent with more conservative
leanings where did you grow up I grew up
in northern Indiana on the outskirts of
a city I was basically in Elkhart
Indiana 30 minutes away from the Amish
from Shipshewana my house was at the end
of a cornfield in the middle of like a
wood so I grew up in a small town in the
Midwest so I grew up on an island north
of Seattle called Whidbey Island yeah it
was super small our main town Langley is
about two streets and I grew up without
television so I have a little bit
different background I grew up with lots
of nature and the radio station when did
you first learn what politics were I
think I first learned about politics
from my dad when I was like six or seven
years old because he would make jokes
like he would make like little one-line
punchline jokes about like other
political parties and I started learning
like oh this will be funny and like that
sides bad and this sides good like my
dad would never say it that plainly but
you could tell from reading between the
lines
I actually remember being like maybe
eight years old and 9/11 had just
happened and I was driving with my mom
we were stopping off at a fast food
place and we walked in and there was a
news reporter there and they were like
how do you feel about this
and I remember smiling because like my
dad had made a joke about like Cuba and
I was like yeah I think it's good that
the president is going to invade Iraq I
think he should do Cuba next because I
thought it would be funny and I had no
idea I was like eight years old and so
of course they put my picture and that
quote and the fact that I was eight
years old like on the front page of our
local newspaper so when I was younger I
really enjoyed going up into my
grandmother's attic and totally digging
through all of her artifacts her pins
buttons travel items all sorts of things
I noticed there was a lot of
conservative buttons of paraphernalia
and I got me thinking how could my
loving wonderful like artistic
grandmother like you know be such a
conservative supporter and on an island
half full of hippies
feels like you would be absolutely
alienated if you were conservative it
was that little inkling when I was
younger that now has blossomed into what
I know now which is that there's
something very different than what we've
been told what was your political
affiliation growing up my political
affiliation growing up was completely
right-wing conservative I would say up
until the age of 12 I had this strong
I felt like my identity was like
Christian homeschooled in Indiana
I remember slapping campaign stickers
for the mccain-palin election like all
over my like notebooks and just like
posting about it on Facebook everyone
around me where I was growing up was
right leaning whether that be hardcore
conservative or Republican libertarian
that was the spectrum so I was
surrounded by Democrats my family was
not too active so we're all kind of like
in that middle zone where you think you
know everyone's a Democrat like that's
the right thing to be and we're fed all
these you know things by the media about
Republicans so it feels not cool to be
that way what made you change your mind
I think it took a few years I think that
I changed my mind through teenage years
into early adulthood I think it really
took growing up and seeing other parts
of the world maturing getting out of my
bubble college moving but I think I
remember what the biggest thing that
took me out of my bubble and it was more
so like a moral standpoint is that I
started doing musical theater around age
12 or 13 and that started exposing me to
a broader sense of the community and I
remember I had tons of friends who were
gay LGBTQIA that must have been the
first Obama election into the second
election that people kept talking about
marriage marriage and civil rights with
LGBT and I remember that being such a
hot topic and people around me in the
community were saying stuff like well
you can have a union but you can't have
a marriage and I was like wait even
being like 16 I'm like that is the
definition of being prejudiced the
political landscape around that time
with marriage equality and LGBT with a
lot of laws being passed from the other
side - like suppress it really really
really push me into a
direction in a different path in the
first election that I got to be a part
of as a voter I really got to think
about politics for the first time so
this was around the time when Facebook
was starting to really take off and I
was seeing a lot of libertarian forums
and different perspectives and I
wondered am I an anarchist like why do I
feel like what's going on politically
with the Democrats is not making enough
change why do I feel like there's a
discordant there and so I started to
explore more groups and I discovered the
Green Party which was a little bit
anarchist and a little bit Pro Earth and
then a little bit of workers rights
which is the main thing I'm now
supporting is the working class the
first time I got to vote I voted for
Jill Stein as a Green Party candidate
when it was MIT Romney versus Obama and
I got a lot of flack for it like why
would you vote Green Party like what is
your vote gonna do but I truly believe
and I still believe that your vote needs
to be a vote of conscience what does
your family think about your beliefs my
family definitely knows I would say take
those angsty teen years when I was 17 or
18 and then when I was like I'm gonna
break free from Amish town I definitely
use that as a way to poke and jab at my
parents I would love to sit down with my
family and have a more mature older
conversation but being in my younger
years I feel like I've directly been
told things like oh I remember when I
went to college and thought I was a
liberal too and then I grew up and I
learned and it's like it's so demeaning
I think the older I get and the more
like healed I get myself that I realize
a lot of people's reflections are
projections of their own understanding
in the beginning my family has been kind
of individualistic when it comes to
politics like it's your personal matter
we don't really want to talk about it
too much because it does get a little
heated I think even on Facebook when I
would make a lot of political posts I
would have family members who I love
very dearly reach out to me and say are
you sure you want to talk about this and
that's when I'm like oh should I even be
trading on people's toes do I want to
make my family feel like maybe I don't
agree with them yeah over time the shift
has been from me being able to express
how I feel to how something will benefit
all of us and so I think that's help the
conversation is how I bring it about as
well I'm trying not to be so divisive
I'm not so pointed I'm trying to be like
okay I understand where you're coming
from and that together like we can get
to the same destination what does your
party stand for my party I feel like is
going through an identity crisis party
has folded in on itself so I feel like
what I define as my party for Democrats
is a little up in the air if media wise
they want me to say it's like carrying a
more like sociologically involved and
like progressive but at the same time I
haven't seen it be ideally my party
would stand for independence and an
entity that is not enchained by another
entity above them ideally my party would
not be paid off by billionaires paid off
by world bank's paid off by other
countries paid off by lobbyists and
corporations where I fall in the
spectrum between libertarian
conservative and justice Democrat social
democrat whatever you want to call it is
absolutely Liberty
it's absolutely patriotism it's health
care it's clean water it's clean food
it's these basic basic rights and then
it's looking back at natural law and our
Constitution and going back to the
foundation so I feel like that structure
can fit into several different parties
it's ultimately who is the party
benefiting is that the corporations or
is it the people and so I'm all about
the people and any party that is for the
people the working-class people and our
rich fellows all of the people because
all the people deserve to have equal
benefit from the government's labor what
do you think is the biggest
misconception about your political party
I would say the biggest misconception
about Democrats is a lot of
misconceptions that are made to
perpetuate stereotypes every single
person is like this feel-good do-gooder
that just loves to pat their own back
and cry in a corner
that's like such a stereotype for
Democrats to me that's not what I've
experienced I've experienced a lot of
it's almost like Democrats have been
associated with being feminine so it's
like they're too soft they're too
emotional and there can be extreme
courage within softness and people don't
get that
the main fear I have as being more
conservative now is being mistaken as a
racist as a anti human as a non
intelligent being I've heard all sorts
of things about conservatives it's
fascinating to hear how both sides have
a very warped perspective of the other
by dehumanizing anyone it just hurts
yourself like ultimately our end goal is
unity and the more we sit around and try
to paint the other person as an animal
the longer it's going to take to get to
where we need to go and you look back in
history and all the terrible things have
happened they've used dehumanizing
tactics to make people feel like they
have a certain supremacy and a privilege
to believe what they do and so we've got
a great painted landscape of division
because of the media thinking that one
side is evil what is one thing you would
change about your political party people
pretending like they're so awake and so
self-aware that they literally shoot
down every single person who is actually
trying to help them in their community
there was actually a time online where I
got into a small argument with a few
people and out of nowhere it turned
political then out of nowhere I remember
I was in like a home depot or someplace
that didn't have phone signal and I was
doing stuff I come out 45 minutes later
and I had hundreds of notifications
personal messages all this stuff they
had gone back into photos of mine from
like 10 years ago when I was 12 years
old and it was a picture of me at a
Sarah Palin rally in Indiana and they
basically had posted it everywhere
saying like look at you you white
Republican you privilege [ __ ] like all
this stuff and I said okay I hear you
I'm listening let's talk and they're
like where's my apology you aren't
responding because you don't care and it
was like there was nothing I could say
do speak anything anything like that
would remedy the situation any
I would take and then on top of it I was
being doxxed I was being threatened on
private message and it was just insane
to me because I felt like we actually
deep down had similar morals and on the
surface voted for the same party so it
was a total mutiny that was a triggered
train chain reaction just by emotions it
was so it's been like five years and I
still think about it I wish I didn't
so for conservatives the main thing that
I would address is just understanding
where the Liberals are coming from like
someone like me who grew up on an island
with a radio instead of television and
who is surrounded by other liberals like
I'm not an evil person because of that
and I only only upon my discovery of
conservative values that I see that we
both have a warped perspective of the
other and that the only reason I felt
that opposition from conservatives
because they thought the same about me
and so now at the end of it I'm seeing
okay conservatives like I understand you
think the Liberals are communist I know
you think they're gonna take everything
from you and your guns but we actually
all kind of want the same things and at
the end of the day you just got to give
people time to come out of the cave you
got to give them time to come from where
they're coming from and all of us are
going to the same place and I think we
all need to just be on an individual
level first and then come to the table
with what we have to offer politically
what do you think about our current
political climate among the death
threats emotional labor and everything I
started seeing that there's not really
any winning I think the conversations I
have now politically is that this whole
liberal Republican deal is binary and it
is a purposeful either/or
black-and-white situation to pit people
against each other so many things in
politics now are just an emotional
trigger on purpose to get people to vote
a certain way and I think that if you
can strip away those labels and strip
away those preconceived notions and talk
to someone human the human being take
away jokes take away trying to be mean
any whatever adjective and speak soul to
soul that then you can start listening
and
I also think it's very important to
ground yourself and if that person wants
to start ranting for an hour let them
rant they want to go through different
emotions and then tell they're ready to
be at a grounded point to actually talk
then you can listen and react back and
forth respectfully the main way I feel
about this political climate is that I
cannot wait for it to be over and I want
to be like beyond 2020 like I'm sorry we
just wasted three years on this Russia
gate hoax on behalf of whatever people
are trying to cause mayhem in our
government where's Ben changes on our
healthcare if you really wanted a third
party opponent were you out doing
grassroots campaigning like what kind of
action have we done it's sad and
ultimately it's okay because it's
exposing what it's supposed to happen
it's exposing this is what our country
is right now I'm sorry like it might be
a big cesspool like metaphorically but
Donald Trump is the pot stirrer he is
stirring the pot and it needs to be
stirred otherwise I'd just be stagnant
toxicity and we would have no change in
the current establishment and so whether
you like Donald Trump or not he is he is
causing there to be a reaction and we
need to address the situation that we
really have a dilemma with which is
corruption and I think that's something
we can all agree on what do you think
about people who believe differently
than you I've been on both sides of the
coin I've literally lived an Amish
country Christian school homeschooled
and I literally have gone to like
socialist like underground meetings
underneath like coffee shops planning
protests there are so many beliefs out
there and it is so ignorant to think
that you know because you don't know
what you don't even know and the older I
get the more I realize I don't even know
myself there's so much out there there's
just no way you know everything to a tee
there's just no way I love people that
think differently than me in every
single way I love every single part of
every person that thinks differently
than me and I ask myself where do I
stand and what do I have to learn from
this person because ultimately at the
end of the day we all came from such
different backgrounds to think that we
would think the same is maniacal it's in
the same my biggest struggle has been
knowing that I don't know
if we do have room to grow it's in the
room of discussion and the more we talk
the more we open ourselves to a
compassionate dialectic where we're not
in fear of what we're gonna say is gonna
get us into trouble that's where unity
is is feeling like okay I feel safe to
be able to say hey like I think
differently than you and what what can
you tell me to make myself maybe think
hey I have more of the picture now
because we don't have all the picture
we're constantly learning like every
single day and until we're dead we're
going to learn
you
[Music]
[Music]